Germany's Afd party is flying high
after reaching 18% support in a recent nationwide poll.
Alternative fr Deutschland
is considered by many to be a far right party
who strongly lean on migration and populist issues
to garner support amongst the population.
The a recent surge in popularity
stems from the disastrous political mismanagement by
the current leadership,
comprised of a union between the SPD,
the FDP and the greens
known as the Traffic Light coalition.
Only 20% of Germans
are satisfied with the current leadership,
so it's no surprise that the people
are looking at the alternative.
Excuse the pun.
Will the Afd ever become the official opposition
or maybe even the ruling party?
And are they really dangerous to democracy?
Let me know what you think in the comments.